the Great Pacific Garbage Patch is one
of the most infamous examples of marine
plastic pollution but it's not actually
a vast island of floating trash
despite its expansive size in places it
can resemble a cloudy soup due to the
presence of micro plastics micro
plastics come in many shapes and forms
fibers from textiles and even cigarette
filters tiny fragments broken off larger
pieces of plastic and microbeads
like those used in toothpastes or face
washes which are small by design of the
10 million tonnes of plastic that enter
the ocean every year only about one
percent floats on the sea surface most
plastic ends up in the deep sea
including micro plastics new research
published in science uncovers a
previously unobserved setting in which
these miniscule pieces of plastic can
accumulate and how these hotspots form
to evaluate micro plastic abundance
researchers examined sediment from a
variety of seafloor features in the
tyranny and sea off the coast of Italy
from the continental shelf and slope
which is closer to the shore to deeper
parts of the water down to 900 meters in
depth one spoonful of sediment contained
a hundred ninety total pieces of plastic
meaning a square metre in the region
could contain upwards of 1.9 million
fragments and fibers to date this is the
highest concentration ever reported for
the seafloor this sample containing 190
pieces was taken from a contour a drift
an area adjacent to strong bottom
currents were gentle slopes of sediment
pile up lower concentrations were found
closer to the shore on the continental
slope and Shelf likely because the
current was too strong for deposits to
form this research demonstrates how deep
ocean currents influence where
microplastics end up similar to how
surface currents play a role in where
garbage patches form these same currents
also circulate vital oxygen and
nutrients to the seafloor
meaning that micro plastic hotspots
could coincide with extremely bio
diverse areas in the future researchers
hope to better understand the source of
these micro plastics by closely
examining their chemical structure
chemists could link plastic pieces to
the industries that created them areas
with other features like submarine fans
and canyons are ripe for the next round
of micro plastic studies as higher
resolution maps of the seafloor emerge
researchers will gain better insight
about where to locate more of the
missing 99% of deep-sea plastic
[Music]